Сучасне мистецтво реагує на зміни в суспільстві
і дуже часто реагує на ті речі,
які залишаются непомітними для багатьох із нас.
Це ще один символ нашої епохи.
Львів перебував на такому дні мистецькому, скажімо так,
бо в принципі жодної незалежної галереї не існувало,
і ми зрозуміли, що треба якось об'єднатися
і висловити свою думку, що так далі бути не може,
бо Львів який несе цей прапор «Ми культурна столиця»,
зайшов уже в глухий кут.
І на етапі цього бунту [культурного]
якраз зі мною були художники.
Сьогодні ми познайомимося з Олексієм Коношенком.
Ми разом з ним обговорювали,
що ж має бути далі з містом.
На етапі таких розмов,
перемовин сформувався кістяк команди
і людей, які з ними зараз також поруч.
Те, що виник муніципальний мистецький центр,
за кошти міста, за бюджетні кошти,
під проводом міської ради,
це вже стало досить таким хорошим знаком,
що можливо ще не все втрачено.
Якщо такий темп буде тривати й надалі
і ці інституційні практики будуть
втілюватись грамотно,
ми будемо далі жити, можливо,
вже в справді в культурній столиці,
хоч як це пафосно і гучно звучить.
Але це те, до чого, можливо, варто прагнути.
Ця історія про враження, про переживання,
про емоції, про події,
після яких
ти перестаєш бути таким, як був.
Про речі, які змінюють тебе і світ навколо.
[Олексій Коношенко, скульптор]
Із нашою архітекторкою простору
арт-центру Христиною Базян
періодично по неділях, ми їздимо
на її машині по смітниках,
і збираємо всілякі такі штуки,
наприклад як тут.
Що у нас тут цікавого?
Старі меблі з вінтажними газетами.
[російською мовою] «Трудное счастье»
Можна це сприйняти як гадання по дорозі?
Майже всі крісла в арт-центрі зі смітників.
Й взагалі, зазвичай люди не дуже
розуміють, що вони викидають,
і ми дуже хочемо цим користуватися.
Скоро Паска, прибирайте,
викидайте все, що вам не подобаєтся,
тільки кажіть де і назвіть адресу.
Коли ми тільки відкривалися, ми запросили жінок,
які працюють в картинній галереї
впродовж 20-30 років наглядачками.
А у нас були абсолютно білі такі зали,
ще абсолютно virgin
(з англ. незаймані, недоторкані).
Ми вирішили, що їх треба освятити.
Ми освятили ці зали присутністю у них цих жінок,
які сидять в картинних галереях впродовж років,
просто вичікують своїх відвідувачів
і дивляться, щоб ніхто нічого руками не чіпав.
Вони сиділи і коментували: «Може, то краще б
дали гроші на якусь лікарню,
тут аналізи нема, де здати», щось ще таке.
А потім одна із них каже:
«Але з іншого боку, якби було місць,
як це, більше,
то нам не довелося би
так часто ходити в лікарню».
Бо люди б приходили, оздоровлювались,
обговорювали це, свої емоції
віддавали б, дивилися на щось гарне.
Я тому продовжую цю думку далі,
що мистецтво, лікарня,
здоров'я, квантова фізика,
якісь такі речі мають бути забезпечені в місті
на такому базовому рівні,
з якого ти потім можеш черпати
базові цінності, ідеї,
натхнення і рухатися далі.
Муніципальний мистецький центр
у Львові має функцію точки зустрічей,
комунікаційного центру,
центру поширення культури,
створення культури, дискусії,
дебатів, лекції, освіти.
Ви одразу потрапляєте
в атмосферу якоїсь колаборації,
руху і різних дивних речей.
Хочется порухати, напевно,
все, що ви тут бачите.
Мені б, напевно, хотілось.
Якби я не рухала все тут останній рік.
До мене, наприклад, приїздять
колеги, художники,
мені нікуди було їх відвести.
Я не мав такого місця,
де можна було прийти і спокійно
поспілкуватись, посидіти.
Навіть якщо є якісь спільні проєкти,
просто на нейтральній території
зустрітись і обговорити їх,
поспілкуватися, за кавою посидіти
в спокійній атмосфері.
У такому чудовому просторі.
Ми хотіли зробити такий простір,
у якому дизайн буде без дизайну.
Все, що було тут старе,
ми хотіли знайти та максимально зберегти,
доповнити це чимось новим.
Створюючи цей інтер'єр,
намагалися взагалі натхнення
забрати на другий план.
Є чіткий функціонал, є акцент на автентику.
Є сучасні меблі й сучасні покриття,
але не більше того.
Тобто тут немає дизайну, його не повинно
в цьому просторі бути.
Весь акцент на експозицію
та речі, які проявляються.
Все інше доповнює.
Я б дуже хотіла, щоб цей простір
змінив всіх-всіх його відвідувачів.
На прикладі того, що ми зробили із стінами,
і того, як ми їх залишили,
щоб це залишилося в їхніх головах
і щоб руйнація автентики зупинилася,
або принаймі зменшила ті обороти,
яких вона набуває зараз.
Щоб люди, які купують кваритири в старих фондах,
чи приміщеня в старих фондах розуміли,
що купили трошки більше, ніж просто приміщення.
Там є історія, є дух,
закладений поколіннями й
там є та якість, якої немає зараз.
Ми не купуємо новобудову,
де хтось індивідуально розмальовував стелі
чи щось вкладав, цей час минув.
Та невідомо коли воно відновиться.
А так, все, що зараз у нас є, —
цінувати нашу історичну спадщину,
та розуміти, що сучасний простір
необов'язково має бути новим повністю з гіпсокартоном.
Він може бути сучасним, але повністю старим.
Це може бути такою п'ятою кімнатою,
якщо її можна так буде назвати,
де ці нові сенси творяться.
І це місце створене, щоб прийти сюди
і вийти далі, творити щось нове.
Хотіла б щоб і наші відвідувачі,
прийшовши сюди, мали настрій і ідеї,
щоб творити щось далі, за межами артцентру.
Але завжди можна вертатися сюди,
щоб отримати тут якісь поради і знайомства
і, можливо, якісь нові вектори свого руху.